VIJAY SAIRAM PRATAP: Thank
you, everybody, for joining us.
Welcome to our
session on how Gap
balances security and
self-service in their API
program.
I am Vijay Sairam Pratap.
I'm a product marketing manager
with Apigee API management
at Google Cloud.
And my co-speaker today
is Patrick, from The Gap.
Patrick, would you like
to introduce yourself?
PATRICK MCMICHAEL:
Hey, thanks, Vijay.
Appreciate the
opportunity to be here
with you to share a little
bit of our API program's story
with you, specifically
as it pertains
towards the criticality
of a developer portal.
I'm an enterprise
architect with Gap.
I'm responsible both for
the structural elements
of our API platform on Apigee,
both in a on-prem data center
as well as in the cloud,
and for shaping our best
practices with the API program.
So thanks for the chance
to share with you today.
VIJAY SAIRAM PRATAP: Awesome.
Thank you, Patrick.
With that, let's dive
straight into the agenda.
Over the next 20
minutes or so, we
are going to look at this
session in two parts.
The first part is going to
cover the new ways of shopping
that are emerging and
how that is changing
the priority for retailers.
And the second piece is
going to focus primarily
on how Gap is
basically executing
its strategy on delivering
self-service capabilities
to its developers.
With that said, let's have
a quick look at the new ways
that the shopping behavior
is changing for consumers.
In this new normal
of lifestyle, I
think consumers are trying new
things and forming new habits.
For example, more than 50%
of the surveyed shoppers
that we polled basically said
that they tried new shopping
experiences for the
very first time.
Nearly 25% of the
shoppers that we surveyed
said that they went online
to purchase something
that, normally, they would
always go to a store for.
And third, nearly 50%
of the surveyed shoppers
clearly said that
they would love
to have the option
of curbside pickup
even after stores reopened.
This tells us something about
the changing shopping behavior.
Obviously, this is
going to make retailers
to rethink their
strategy in terms
of the areas of investment and
priorities in this new world
normal.
In the interest of
time, while I have
five areas that have been
called out on the slide,
I will focus on two of them
that I am very passionate about.
One is boosting
online experience.
As of today,
retailers are looking
at their e-commerce
investments and ramping it up
so that they are able to take
on this huge tsunami of demand
that they are seeing emerging
on their digital platforms.
Second, they're also looking
at how to amplify and leverage
the data that
they're receiving so
as to create greater
personalized offers
for their customers.
And the third most
important thing
is that retailers
are now looking
at the aspect of how
to repurpose some
of their existing investments
in the form of stores
into mini fulfillment
locations, and also looking
at how they can repurpose
some of their store associates
to become fulfillment managers.
The second area where
they're reimagining customer
interactions-- customers are
now experimenting more and more
with technologies like
video, AR, commerce,
live events, et cetera.
There's a lot more
tendency of them
leaning into completely
adopting a digital approach
to their retailer.
The second is the
retailers themselves
realize the kind of
high call volumes
that are being generated
because of this new normal
and are trying to adapt in
areas like customer service,
leveraging the power of AI
to see how they can enable
virtual agents to have very
effective conversations
with their customers--
also, having
some of their virtual
agents being expert
assist agents for
their human agents.
So all these things
are happening
in the retail world from
a reimagining customer
interactions perspective.
And retailers are now looking
at investing more and more
into sophisticated clienting
solutions for associates,
shopping experience
assistant apps for consumers
so that they can have a better
shopping experience when
they are in the store, and
other more fulfillment options.
Well, all these
changes are happening.
At the heart of all
the changes, to deliver
on the above mentioned
priorities that we discussed,
retailers need to focus on APIs.
As we know, APIs are nothing
but application programming
interface.
APIs are key enabler for
most of these priorities
that we spoke about and are
the de facto building blocks
for building and sharing
modern applications
in today's enterprise market.
And second most important
piece is the enablement
of developers to leverage
these APIs in the least--
with the least amount of
friction so as to create
new world experiences.
So how do we empower
developers with APIs?
That's going to be
the question that we
are going to try and answer
in the next couple of slides.
While APIs are key
enablers, a first step
towards handling APIs
is to basically have
an API management platform.
You need these APIs to
be delivered securely.
They should be
managed and analyzed
across a multitude
of your environments,
be it on premises, cloud,
private cloud, SaaS,
and other IT endpoints.
To navigate this
complexity and to be
able to manage your APIs
in a structured fashion
as a product, you need an
enterprise-grade API management
platform.
Apigee is a multi-cloud
API management platform.
It gives businesses control
over, and visibility into, APIs
that connect applications and
data across the enterprise
and across clouds.
Apigee empowers organizations
to accelerate their business
by unlocking the value
of data and delivering
modern applications,
such as curbside pickup,
instantaneously.
So if you look at the
API management platform,
you'll see it has
four distinct areas.
The first area is API gateway.
Helps us basically
expose services and data
as consumable APIs.
The second layer is mediation.
Mediation engine enables you to
basically manipulate messages
as they flow through
the API proxies.
They enable you to transform
messages, like from XML
to JSON, vice versa, et cetera.
The third part is
what is going to be
the focus of this presentation,
developer ecosystem,
a section of the
management platform
that helps you manage the
community of app developers
that are using your
APIs, leveraging
your data or your services.
Helps you to work for
both internal and extended
developers, and
formalizes a relationship
with financial models,
and onboards developers
with the creation of
a developer portal.
And the last piece is analytics.
As the name suggests, the
more you're able to measure,
the better are you able to
improve your interactions
with your consumers.
All the above mentioned
areas play a critical role
in helping you deliver
your API's products.
For today's session,
as mentioned,
we'll look at the
developer ecosystem part.
Building API great
products is just
the start of an API program.
There is no doubt that
while publishing an API
is a major milestone,
but it's just
the beginning of the process.
The hardest part is-- once
you have published your API's
products, is-- to
attract and engage
developers who will
build apps leveraging
the APIs that you have created.
So now let's look at, what
are the three main ingredients
that go into creating an
effective delivery platform?
It's all about
product-market fit.
Know your customer and consumer.
Are they internal consumers?
Are they external API consumers?
Are they partner consumers?
That tells you a lot.
Understanding the
requirements helps
you package the
product in the best way
possible to enhance
product-market fit.
The second is, bring
your APIs to market.
It's like the [INAUDIBLE]
five P's of marketing mix.
Place-- digital
storefront is important as
to help your developers
to find your APIs,
to interact with them,
to learn with them,
and to actually
engage with them.
And the last is,
build a relationship.
This is about creating
a bi-directional flow
of information where a great
developer experience starts
with your ability to be able to
onboard, get developers to get
fast-tracked to their
hello world API,
and more importantly,
give them an option
to solve the problems by
themself without having
to depend on too much
of human intervention.
So we spoke about what are the
three main ingredients that are
required in a developer portal.
So now let's look at the overall
advantages of the developer
portal.
And if we look at
the developer portal,
there are four major advantages
to the developer portal.
The first advantage is
it improves discovery.
Stop recreating the wheel.
You have the ability of
surfacing all your APIs
in a structured fashion over
a developer portal, which
will help the ability for
people to search, identify,
and consume those APIs.
By just improving the discovery,
depending on your business
case, you actually help
improve your relationship
with your consumer
whether they are
API consumers from the internet
part of your organization
or those external.
So discovery is a
very important part.
The second is the aspect of
streamlining, and onboarding,
and self-service.
This is the place
where you basically
help your API
consumers to security
and quickly gain access to
the tools and information
that they need to explore,
test, and consume APIs.
examples-- [INAUDIBLE].
I'm sure you heard about that.
The third piece is learn and--
learn from usage and improve.
This is the part of
optimizing API programs
with the power of analytics,
with the power of API
performance analytics.
Helps you gain
visibility into the APIs.
[INAUDIBLE] service
quality, volumes
are rising across
pricing tiers, and more.
It also gives you deeper
visibility into API performance
and how developers use them.
Use this data to understand app
performance, traffic patterns,
issues to better make this-- to
make better business decisions.
And the last part is security.
API abuse will be the most
frequent attack vector
resulting in data breaches for
enterprise web applications
in 2022.
That's what Gartner says.
You need to ensure
the fact that you
can leverage the
capabilities of the developer
portal the package
your API products
and deliver them with
role-based permission,
manage product access and
security with built-in app
registration, and support
for automatic and manual
API key approval.
You can do all this with the
help of your developer portal.
At Apigee, we do have a
very robust developer portal
strategy.
And it is a tool
that will help you
build a world-class
developer experience.
It basically has three
main components--
catalog, which
helps you discover,
enables discovery, branding,
theming, search; content, which
enables learning, the QA,
the blog forums, the support,
and the analytics that you can
provide through the platform.
And the last is relationship,
the bi-directional relationship
that we spoke about to
develop identity, app and key
request, governance,
and API consumer funnel.
Apigee developer portal
comes, basically,
in two flavors, the first one
being the integrated developer
portal, and the second one
being a Drupal-based portal.
And the considerations
with this we
have seen across our
customers primarily
hinge on two main parameters--
the amount of
configuration I want to do,
or the amount of
coding I want to do,
and second is a very simple
budget and time availability.
Great, now that we've seen the
advantages of the developer
portal, we understand how
Apigee can help you build
a world-class developer portal.
Now let's try and
bust this myth about,
a developer portal is only
for external developers
and for partners.
Is that really so?
Let's talk to
Patrick and find out
as to how Gap is
busting this myth.
Patrick, over to you.
PATRICK MCMICHAEL:
Thanks a lot, Vijay.
Appreciate the chance
to share with you what
this is looking like us at Gap,
why we believe that integrated
development portal is
exactly the way we solve some
of our most pressing challenges
for an internal developer
audience.
Before I do that, let me share
with you just a little bit
about our company.
Gap has been around
for just over 50 years.
Started out in 1969
as a single store
doing blue jeans and vinyl
records, both of which--
jeans are still as
in style as ever.
And thank god vinyl records
have made a comeback.
Today, Gap is a
multi-brand, global company,
but with, still, those same
values that have driven them
for over 50 years.
Specific to our API program--
as I've joined our team,
I've watched an API program
grow into hundreds of APIs.
The API platform team is
onboarding both API producer
and consumer teams.
And we'll talk more
about those two personas
in just a little bit here.
We are onboarding multiple
teams every single day.
We've grown into over
200 developer apps
where those teams--
if you're a producer team,
for developing and testing
your APIs, if you're
a consumer team,
for weaving those APIs into
amazing customer experiences.
Billions of API calls,
every single year,
are flowing through
the Apigee platform,
both in our own data
center as well as,
now, in the cloud
across multiple regions.
What does it look
like as you go and try
to grow your API program,
and your scale and complexity
increases?
When I first joined the API
program a few years ago,
we had two major
business initiatives,
one that was
customer-facing, one which
was workforce-user-facing.
And we had about a
dozen to 18 core APIs
that both of those programs
were focused on and relying on
to meet their
business objectives.
Fast-forward five years,
and those 12 to 18 core APIs
is now hundreds of APIs.
I laugh now, but at
the time we started
this, those were managed in
a Google spreadsheet trying
to keep track on where
each of those were,
which were in development,
which were ready for prime time.
No way on Earth that scales
to what we're facing today.
I want to talk about this
from the perspective of two
key personas.
Number one is the API consumer.
What is the pressing
question that persona has?
When can I start
accessing your API?
They are hounding our API
producer teams and the Apigee
platform team on a daily basis.
They are under
tight commitments.
They've got deadlines to meet.
They've got budgets they
have to stay within.
As was discussed in the
introduction here by Vijay,
COVID and the pandemic
has caused teams
to be able to need to
pivot faster than ever.
The rules of the
game, what you can
do in store, what
you can do online,
that is changing on a daily
basis and region by region.
What about the API producers?
Their number one
pressing question
is, I want to, as
consumer teams,
meet these business objectives.
Is my API ready for prime time?
Great, I've written my back
end at business implementation.
I have a proxy that
I've wrapped that with.
But is it really ready to
turn loose to the masses yet?
What we've learned over
these last few years
in evolving our
program is that an API
goes through a life cycle.
It all starts with
an Open API spec.
Apigee Edge includes a great
Open API spec 3 compliant spec
editor.
That becomes a point
of conversation
between the team producing the
API and our infosec partners.
It's critical that that be done
at the early part of the life
cycle.
What happens if that's
delayed is a team
can be on the verge of
a production go-live
only to find they have to
go back 10 steps backwards.
When you have those
conversations up front
in an agile, fail
fast mentality,
it's very cheap to make changes.
Maybe infosec says
a given API needs
to be locked down a
little bit tighter,
so it's going to use OAuth
tokens instead of keys.
Maybe there's
manipulation that needs
to happen on a JSON payload
coming out of that API
for a subset of the audiences
that's less privileged.
Those contractual
details are worked out.
Then you start
dropping lines of code.
You build your
Apigee proxy, which
is just as much a part of
that API contract as the API
implementation itself.
It proceeds on to
infosec for pen testing.
If you've got Black Friday
haunting your dreams at night,
you are load testing those APIs.
And eventually, you
are lighting that up
for the world, which is
what we're doing this
for in the first place.
That life cycle is a
huge balancing act.
The consumer teams
are like the kid
in the back seat of the car
on the way to Disney World.
Are we there yet?
They want the lowest-friction
self-service experiences
absolutely possible.
Meanwhile as Vijay mentioned,
APIs are a huge attack vector.
None of us like the G word,
but governance is essential
if you're going to have
a successful API program.
You've got to make sure
those I's are dotted
and T's are crossed, and
that your APIs are secure,
both those that are exposed on
your internal network and any
of those that may be exposed
on your external network.
As we've gone through our
evolution of the program
and built this life cycle into
the way APIs are developed
and made ready for
consumption, we've
found two major
challenge areas I want
to talk about real quickly.
Number one is you have to
have a single source of truth.
When it comes to
understanding which
APIs have gone through
that requisite gating,
you've got to be able
to go to one place
and understand what's there.
And for us, the perfect
place to make that happen
is the developer portal.
If you don't see it, it's
not ready for prime time.
And that may vary.
In that early part
of the life cycle,
the only people who
can see that API
should be the owning
team and infosec.
As it's gone through all
that gating that I described,
it's now going to be lit up
for any API consumer audience.
The second part has to
do when a team comes in
to request access to an API
once it is ready for prime time.
We have huge
communication challenges.
You may have a API consumer
team with 10 developers.
And they're reaching out to the
Apigee platform team for access
to this API that they need to
meet their next deliverable
for the business.
And they're going on three
different communication
channels with 10 different
people effectively asking
for the same thing, but under
just as many different names.
It creates confusion,
redundant effort,
and cleanup that's required.
These two challenges,
we believe,
the Apigee integrated
developer portal
is really well-positioned
to address.
But I would rather
show you than tell you.
So with that, let me
switch into a demo.
So I'd like to take
some of these concepts
that we've been talking
about and show you what
they look like in practice.
So we've talked about APIs
going through a life cycle
and progressively being
opened up for access
to a wider set of audiences.
So here we've got
two APIs, USPTO
and an end of month reporting.
This first one, you'll see,
is available to everybody.
That has gone fully
through the gating cycle.
It's been certified by infosec.
It's been load tested.
It is ready for prime time.
So it's available not only to
the owning team and to infosec,
but now to the
consumers as well.
The second API is earlier
in that life cycle
and is only available to the
team that's building that API,
and then to infosec.
The other concept
we talked about
is how you get in to
governing that kind of access
as it goes through
that lifecycle
and there's a few key things
you want to see in Apigee Edge
here.
Number one are
developer accounts.
These are users who have
created accounts for themselves
within the developer portal.
Those users may choose to
create teams, which they
will be then made the owner of.
They can add additional
members to those teams.
And then there is this
concept of audiences.
We've got our broad audiences
of API consumers, API producers,
and then our infosec
pen testing team.
Now right now, each of
these has one team each.
But there could certainly
be multiple teams
that are all considered in
an API consumer audience,
for example.
You also, when something is
ready for full consumption
by everybody, have the
ability to simply say,
if you're authenticated to
the portal, you can see this.
So those are the ideas
that we have within Edge.
So now let's look at
things from the perspective
of the developer portal itself.
Right now I'm logged
in with a user that's
going to simulate being a tech
lead on one of the API producer
teams.
That tech lead has
gone in, instantiated
a team, Slick APIs.
They are an API producer team.
That user is the
owner of that team,
but is able to delegate
responsibilities
to other users who can
also help in that day in,
day out administration.
You'll also notice that
this team currently
has access to one application
suffixed with "DevOps," which
is a naming convention
for API producer teams
where the APIs they access are
those which they are developing
and accessing purely for purpose
of evolution and testing.
We talked about those
two APIs before,
one that's already
ready for prime time--
so you see this team owns
that-- and then a new one, which
is undergoing development.
Now let's come in instead as
that user that was delegated
responsibility within this team.
So if that user logs
in, you'll notice
that they can see that team
they were made a member of.
They have admin access.
Notice none of this is editable.
So they don't have
quite the same access
as an owner would have.
But they can drill
into that application.
Now this particular
developer on this team
is actually the one responsible
for this end-of-month reporting
application.
So they're going to
go ahead and add that
so that they can evolve
that API, its back end,
and its front end proxy.
They can leverage the
API key and the secret,
whether those
endpoints are governed
based on the infosec discussions
by API key or by OIDC token.
All of that is
available for them.
Now let's say this user
has taken this far enough,
and they're now ready to
have infosec begin pen
testing on that application.
What does that look like?
So we're going to come in now
simulating a member of the pen
testing team.
That user is going to come in.
They can go to the application
that they use for pen testing.
And they've been working
on this other one.
That's already graduated,
ready for prime time.
They'll go ahead and
remove that if they
don't need that at the moment.
But they're going
to go ahead and add
this new one,
leveraging the same key
and secret they've been using,
to commence that pen testing.
So this API, so far, has
visibility to a infosec pen
testing audience as well as
the audience of the owning API
producer team.
Now let's come in from the
perspective of a consumer.
So we're going to come in as
the owner of the consuming API
team.
They're building an application
that needs this API.
And you'll see there's
already a team in place
for this API consumer team.
This user is an owner.
And they've already
delegated responsibility
to one of the members
of that team that's
also doing development work.
So that user is there.
Now right now, there
are no applications.
We mentioned, during the
introduction on this talk,
that the COVID
pandemic has really
shifted the way retailers
are doing their business.
And one of those is this
notion of curbside pickup.
So we're going to
go ahead and create
an application for that
called Curbside Delight.
And it's going to go ahead
and use that product that's
all ready for prime time.
But they also know
they're going to need
the functionality that
the end-of-month reporting
API provides.
Notice that, right now,
that is not visible.
So I want to stop a minute
and talk about those two
key challenges that we've
observed these last few years.
Number one was single
source of truth.
We said, if you see
it, it's available.
If you do not see it, it is
not yet ready for prime time.
So notice the limited audience
for the end-of-month reporting
API was the owning
team and infosec.
But a consuming team
cannot yet see that.
That's that single source
of truth, all in the portal.
Second thing we talked
about was communication.
Even for those APIs that
are ready for prime time,
one of the things that
frequently happens
is multiple members
of the same team
will come in and make
requests, some of them
by text, some of them
by email, some of them
by ServiceNow tickets, all
effectively for the same API,
but leveraging different
names for the API
they're trying to get, for the
dev app they want it added to,
for what team they're a part of.
Creates endless confusion
and a lot of redundancy.
Notice here, this user
came in, could see
their team, their apps.
And when they did that
self-service request,
it was already completely clear
what they were looking for.
Now In this case, they can get
one of the two that they need,
but not the second one.
That's going to prompt them to
go talk with that API producer
team and find out
what's going on.
Now let's assume that they
have that conversation,
and infosec says, you
know what, we just
completed our pen testing.
The owning producer
team, in the meanwhile,
has been doing
their load testing.
That is now certified.
This API is ready
to be graduated.
So previously, it was visible
only to the owning team
and infosec.
We are now going to make this
API visible to everybody.
We're doing that
through consumers.
You could also choose to
move away from audiences
and just say any
authenticated user depending
on your requirements
and your configuration.
We're simply going to add
consumers to this mix.
Now if I come back in as the
member of that team that's
consuming this, that needs
end-of-month API access,
they can drill right
into the application.
And notice they now
have visibility to this.
That app has
graduated all gating
and is now ready for broad
consumption, self-service.
And they've got
themselves access to this.
So you've seen a
few key concepts.
We've demonstrated
this idea that you
can have this
experience, which is
self-service, low-friction,
simplifies communication,
leverages the portal as a single
source of truth, all while
not having to sacrifice
governance that's
key to a secure API program.
Hopefully this gave you an idea.
You might do this a
little bit differently
in your organization.
But hopefully it
gives you a sense
of what a developer
portal workflow might
look like for an internal
developer audience
like we have.
I hope if you've gotten
anything out of the talk here,
it's a handful of key concepts.
Number one, if you want
an API program that's
focused on innovation
and agility,
you have to have a
low-friction experience.
Without that, it becomes
frustrating for everyone
involved.
But that low-friction,
self-service experience cannot
come at the sacrifice
of security.
API governance does
have to be there.
We believe that a
developer portal gives me
a way to achieve both
of those, to find
that balance between the two.
They don't have to be at
odds with one another.
There's a way to have both.
And we think the Apigee
integrated developer
portal is exactly the right
way to accomplish this for Gap.
There's a lot of
developer options.
I would be the
first to tell you,
your organization
may be better-suited
for the Drupal portal.
Another organization
like ours, we
believe the integrated developer
portal is the better fit.
You guys pick the one that
fits your needs the best.
VIJAY SAIRAM PRATAP: Great.
Thank you, Patrick.
That was amazing.
I loved, I loved, I loved
the example of the Sheets.
Oh my god, imagine
managing all those APIs
through a spreadsheet.
But you know what, I think
Gap has come a long way.
And really envious about
the kind of progress
that you folks have made
and are continuing to make.
So I think the
takeaways were great,
but I have one question for you.
If you were to change one
thing about how you did things,
what would it be, and why?
PATRICK MCMICHAEL: If I
could go back five years
and do anything
different, it would
be to make sure that from
day one, out of the gate,
we had that developer
portal in place.
We're in process of moving
from OPDK to hybrid.
As we do that, that opens
up the door for using
the integrated developer portal
the way I've demoed it here,
unblocks us on all
these major challenges.
But if I could go
back, we would have had
that portal live from day one.
We would have built
those process flows
with that low-fiction but good
governance balance already
in place.
And we would have built that
collective muscle memory
around what those workflows look
like, leveraging the portal,
so that that's not something
you transition into later,
it's your starting
reality from day one.
VIJAY SAIRAM PRATAP: Awesome.
Thank you, Patrick.
This has been great.
Thanks a lot for taking
the time to join us.
I would like to
thank everybody who
has joined us for the session.
I hope you had some
nice key takeaways.
One major takeaway for me
is, don't let a developer
portal be an afterthought.
Ensure the fact that it's a
part of your thought process
as you're putting together
your API-led digital strategy.
With that said, thank
you, and have a great day.